oui
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans la grande
interview
cette semaine à l'occasion du trophy
taux de l'uefa en vue de l'hérault 2020
décalé en raison du coc vide
nous recevons à l'ancien international
français david trezeguet bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
donc avant de vous parler de football je
voudrais quand même posé une question
concernant comment moscou et
saint-pétersbourg la russie en général
vous accueille mais les deux villes que
je veux j'ai vu la possibilité de
connaître qu'ils soient sans pétersbourg
est ici franchement très bien excellente
selon le côté le côté vie et vivre ça
veut dire en gros les gens ils sont
contents beaucoup de disponibilité
beaucoup de déjà au niveau compétition
avec beaucoup d'envié qui ça commence et
sans oublier que
la russie va avoir la possibilité
d'avoir le public c'est quelque chose de
exceptionnel à partir de là on attend
avec beaucoup d'impatience sur le début
de la compétition mais sinon à chaque
fois que j'ai la possibilité de venir à
réussissent avec beaucoup beaucoup de
plaisir et justement quel est le regard
que vous portez sur là aussi la rive six
mois j'ai vu la possibilité déjà ou de
l'avoir connue mais mais je pense qu'à
prier et 2018 il ya il ya une image très
forte guy équipe qui est restée par
rapport déjà par rapport aux supporters
cette image de 2 ça a été une fête la
coupe du monde ça a été une fête et
c'est sûr que par rapport à la france
en plus avec la possibilité d'avoir
gagné la coupe du monde mais on a senti
la volonté la halle envie de
de montrer leur pays et ça a été réussi
ça a été ils ont montré une qualité
inoubliable et à partir de là je compte
sur 200 pays qui qui entraîne aussi de
se développer et et ont bien avec
beaucoup de disponibilité quand on a la
possibilité
justement pendant la coupe du monde vous
avez dit que c'était justement la
meilleure coupe de l'histoire qu'est ce
qui vous a justement impressionné le
plus pauvre du monde
mais il faut dire qu'avant la coupe du
monde 2018 on avait peut-être l'idée
d'un pays
très ferme et discipliné et
il y en a vu la disponibilité
l'ouverture et
de montrer leurs qualités bien sûr qu'au
niveau jour restée très déjà haut niveau
ce n'est pas surpris parce que je
connais c'est quand même mais au niveau
stade c'était des stades de top niveau
il ya près tout ce qui est au niveau de
la mission fut ma disponibilité à y
avait une envie de bien faire une envie
de montrer leur pays que
l'accueil des gens peut être la seule
voilà la colt c'était impressionnant
avec surtout la beaucoup de
disponibilité de la part de russes de
vouloir montrer nous on vouloir donner
en plus et c'est pour ça que mon avis ça
a été une coupe du monde exceptionnelle
en étant en étant supporté avons
introduit mais et mais ça a été très
bien passé d'accord la france commence à
reprendre goût à la vie justement avec
la réouverture des bars des cinémas des
stades notamment comment avez vous vécu
justement cette période de la pandémie
ça a été une année difficile une année
on a beaucoup réfléchi à pas mal de
choses ça veut dire la première des
choses la famille brillante de réflexion
que d'être voilà des réflexions que
jusqu'ici on n'avait pas fait de d'en
profiter
beaucoup plus la vide
de retrouver les choses plus simples le
quotidien qu'est ce que vous allez
retrouver des mois déjà au titre
personnel et je profitais pour passer
mes diplômes en étant directeur sportif
et entraîneur j'ai beaucoup profité les
lits des deux
de finir mes études avant tout après
la famille proche en sachant que la
pandémie a
bien laisser des traces aussi il faut le
dire mais plus de l'otan ils passent ils
sont que revient à la vie qui ont m
mais il faut il faut savoir la profiter
aussi je trouve là déjà de l'idée de
d'avoir la possibilité de venir déjà
réussi deux mots de mon côté ça a été
quelque chose que j'avais oublié entre
guillemets mais mais la pandémie on a je
pense qu'on était conscient comme qu'il
faut en profiter la vie beaucoup plus
avec du respect avec eux
et sans oublier que finalement il faut
faire très attention à sa santé et à la
santé des autres santé mentale peut être
sait il faut aussi respecter voilà
respecter des choix et peut-être au
début on n'était pas conscient peloton
il est passé il y en a on a su s'en
sortir je prends ce que dans la
globalité au monde on a su s'en sortir
même si encore toujours il faut faire
attention il faut
être attentif mais prenez sur la voie
qu'il faut pour beaucoup le foot a été
synonyme d'évasion durant cette période
de la pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise
mais on a vu que le football finalement
à donner un plus au niveau émotionnel
aux gens ça veut dire que même si après
avec l'otan on a dit dommage que le
stade les hauts niveaux stade soit
fermée mais je pense qu'on a su profiter
aussi de couper la vie une vie quand
même difficile en étant en étant la
maison ou en étant un trou qui m'est
fait à mes seins fermes et voilà le
footballeur a montré encore que il ya le
côté passionnel il ya le côté émotion
mais aussi
voila ca le sport plus populaire qui on
aime le profiter avec les amis en
famille au même tout seul commencent à
arriver au 6 mai
je pense que
ça a été quelque chose d utile en
sachant respectant et tout haut ce qui
est un niveau santé mais je pense ça a
été bien de continuer le football pour
s'évader un peu aussi haut niveau au
niveau mental vous êtes aujourd'hui en
russie dans le cadre du trophée dont 2
les fans que représente cette coupe pour
vous cette compétition vous avez quand
même une belle histoire avec le voilà
une très belle histoire non après 98 on
gagne la coupe du monde est la première
nation à remporter ensuite appris aux
championnats d'europe les deux coupes
qui au niveau équipe nationale c'est
l'idée l'envi le rêve et moi au titre
personnel en plus marqué pendant la
finale contre l'italie ça veut dire que
j'ai eu la chance de regagner les deux
trophées les plus importants au niveau
nationale et ça a été quelque chose de
inoubliable et plus le ton il passait
plus peut-être au début on fait pas
attention aux titres qu'on a gagné mais
après après plus de temps il passe ou
non voilà on fait le
mons est d une rencontre avec la coupe
depuis très longtemps et ça me touche au
bo à vous avez arrêté votre carrière en
2014 quel regard portez-vous sur toutes
ces années à monaco à la cheville tous
en équipe de france
le foot ça a été ma vie ma passion mes
rêves
au niveau professionnel monsieur niveau
vie personnelle je suis encore dans la
ligne même en étant dans un autre
contexte en étant ambassadeur et suivre
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné dans tous
les contextes
à partir de là je respecte le football
je respecte les gens j'ai la possibilité
de le côtoyer plus avec les gens avec
les supporters et chose qui quand on est
footballeur peut être on a moins de
possibilités mais en étant
et l'après voilà ça ça me touche ça me
fait plaisir
on est tous conscients que le football
il nie tout ce qui est au niveau social
surtout au niveau culture et je fais
partie des avec alors ça me touche à
beaucoup de joueurs parlent de petite
mort lorsqu'il quitta les terrains
comment avez vous vécu cette période
justement ça va ça va et
et entre temps
je sentais que surtout au niveau
physique un niveau mental et peut-être
c'était le moment de passer à une autre
chose de ma vie
les trous de rattraper aussi ouais mais
je sentais que petit à petit je sentais
la fin et bien je prends là c'est là que
je commençais à
à faire mes cours aussi et en sachant
que je voulais rester liée au football
et ça n'a pas été difficile par rapport
à moi mais avec le temps en discutant en
parlant avec beaucoup d amis un
finalement des coéquipiers ex
coéquipiers c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile quand on est quand on a vécu une
vie au surtout on a été protagoniste
aussi on a connu le haut niveau
l'après est pour beaucoup c'est pas été
évident dans mon cas c'était plus simple
mais on a là on a la volonté hall envie
de ne se pas faire oublier
et quand on a la chance de revenir en
étant ambassador dans le contexte où je
me trouve aujourd'hui ça fait beaucoup
du plaisir surtout la voir les gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a
faits n'ont surtout au niveau niveau
football et ça c'est touchant et vous
enfants à convoite il le jure que vous
avez été et ce qu'ils ont conscience que
vous avez marqué l'histoire du sport
cbas d'un côté mes enfants ils sont pas
sots faire la notoriété du père ça veut
dire qu'ils sont faits une envie et ça a
été ma ligne de conduite aussi ça veut
dire mes parents ils m'ont jamais mis
une pression pour mes décisions au
niveau football je trouvais ça
une ligne de conduite correcte et ça a
été mon idée vers mes enfants je pense
qu'il ya un moment où chacun doit faire
son parcours et chacun doit faire ses
projets et voilà mon fils il est qu'il
est il est avec moi et ils
m'accompagnent il est content il est
fier et il apprend aussi l'apprend le
gua en sachant que son père b il a fait
un parcours et une histoire forte et ça
nous motive ça ça fait ça fait plaisir
aux titres aux personnes justement votre
fils est né aaron qui est qui est
maintenant sportif accompli ce qui vous
demandent peut-être des conseils dans
son dans sa carrière
plus que plus que deux conseils et bons
il a une hygiène de vie pour devenir un
professionnel se souvient il
il est né comme ça il est il est né dans
un contexte où il a vu son père au titre
professionnel aussi non il tire
peut-être quelque chose de votre
expérience en quatre parties l'envié je
pense c'est la plage je trouve que quand
on fait du sport de haut niveau
bien sûr qu'il ya le côté professionnel
il ya le côté personnel privé mais à mon
avis a le côté surtout le côté émotion
dans le sport est et dans l'émotion il
faut trouver lundi
et quand on a envie de faire son
parcours on a beaucoup plus de
possibilités
encore une fois un peu ma ligne de
conduite de voir les choses et depuis
très longtemps on a eu la possibilité de
dîner ensemble je vois je sens qu'il qui
qu'il aime le monde du sport et ça c'est
bien je pense aussi bien pour la vie le
quotidien du sport sait c'est quelque
chose de bien on parle d' exemplarité
par rapport à vos enfants mais qu en est
il par rapport à la nouvelle génération
est ce que le fait d'avoir été par
exemple décoré de la légion d'honneur en
1998 ampli qu'une forme de
responsabilité oui et non je pense le
temps moi je te dis au niveau
professionnel il faut il faut dire il
faut accepter après voir si un positive
ou négative le football a beaucoup
changé
surtout quand on voit les réseaux
sociaux et dans lequel on vit et où on
montre beaucoup plus de choses qu'avant
peut-être personnel avant le football
avait existé en code de être peut-être
beaucoup plus privé là il faut s'adapter
à cette nouvelle génération nous c'est
beaucoup plus ouvert ou montre beaucoup
plus des choses mais qu'il faut faire
attention aussi à partir de là bien sûr
que moi je me sens dans l'idée de
montrer une voie de
des gens en étant ici montrer mon
professionnalisme aussi ça fait partie
de ma vie ma culture mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut à s'adapter à cette nouvelle
idée de voir les choses d'une autre
manière
le footballeur et il est un devoir
d'exemplarité
je pense qu'ils en dévoilant des voiries
l'année voir ce que nous ils sont il
faut dire qu'ils sont et qu'ils
ressemblent de deux vers surtout vers
les gens bien vers les l'âge de on est
tous conscients que le football le sport
populaire où beaucoup d des joueurs et
font un parcours peut-être pas facile
il faut être conscient aussi que
le côté économique aussi fait partie de
la vie d'un professionnel mais il faut
faire très attention en essayant
toujours de faire les bons choix d'avoir
à ses côtés des gens responsables et à
mon avis ici site à cette ligne de
conduite après tout ça devient beaucoup
plus facile et tu peux être un excellent
un exemple le très claires et précises
pour parler un peu des jeux qui se passe
actuellement la juventus vagues
potentiellement perdre sa plus grande
star cristiano ronaldo lors du mercato
de l'été
que pensez vous de son apport au club et
de son actuel peut être des parcs
certains parlent d'un fiasco est ce que
vous êtes d'accord
cristiano ronaldo et à donner une image
très positive au championnat italien
jose cobo choqué l'italie a su profiter
de cette image au niveau club et
cristiano ronaldo a signé dans le club
le plus important en italie en sachant
que la juventus au niveau national
depuis dix ans il fait un parcours très
fort c'est vrai que niveau international
ligue des champions existait l'ambition
de mieux faire avec aussi et cristiano
ronaldo
et cristiano ronaldo doit décider avec
le club si continuer ensemble au pas et
beyer la juventus et qui se qualifie à
la ligue des champions je pense que
c'est quelque chose de bien et cristiano
ronaldo en trois ans il a marqué plus de
100 buts à mon avis au titre personnel
il a fait un parcours exceptionnel en
sachant que l'idée de gagner la ligue
des champions il est resté loin mais en
sachant aussi que voilà avec un seul
joueur tu peux pas gagner cette
compétition ça ça a été très clair et
après il ya des choix à faire il ya des
choix à faire qui soit le club qu'ils
soient qui sait depuis quelques années
on parle de alan et de mba paix comme le
futur du football quel regard
portez-vous est sur ces deux joueurs
est ce qu'ils ont peut-être les qualités
pour marquer l'histoire
à mon avis la pré messi cristiano
ronaldo c'est clair que il ya une ligne
très marquée par rapport à un bape et
violent c'est le présent mais celles à
venir
et voilà ils y ont voient c'est des
joueurs avec un professionnalisme de la
qualité de volonté et de la vie et
surtout quand on voit les ligaments les
enfants
voilà leur idole des shows aussi ceux
des joueurs qui avec l'otan ils vont
être obligés faire les choix des jo
niveau club
oui justement concernant qu'il y en a
fait et ce qu'il doit quitter justement
psg pour devenir un super entre player
est ce que vous vouliez concept est
train de guider un bape et il est dans
un club avec beaucoup d'ambition mais il
est dans un pays où catalogué que le
football de haut niveau samedi dans d
autres pays
quand on dit dans d autres pays on est
tous conscients que le championnat
anglais le championnat espagnol
le championnat italien et là le
championnat de l'allemagne aussi ça fait
partie de trois quatre top au niveau
international imap et avec le temps bien
sûr qu'il va à mon avis sentir le besoin
de de connaître un autre contexte
est ce ça fait partie de la de l'avis
d'un professionnel
ça va être le même cas à laon il est
dans un club avec
une histoire avec de l'ambition mais non
c'est pas le bayer avec un attaque
benzema mbacké griezmann est ce que les
bleus sont ils les favoris mais les
bleus depuis depuis
ils peuvent répéter justement votre à
mon avis c'est l'idée il faut pas
oublier que le temps dans nos
championnats d'europe en france la
france on perd la finale contre le
portugal
après un parcours suivi en gagnant 2018
et là l'idée c'est très clair d'aller
jusqu'au bout pour gagner la compétition
la chose qui est clair c'est que
l'équipe de france il ya de la qualité
et nord il ya des joueurs exceptionnels
il y a des joies avec de l'avenir et la
france et les candidates à la nuit merci
merci à vous
[Musique]